this is a daily reminder to Iraqis
living in Baghdad their country is among
the world's richest in energy
but for this man and those living here
power cuts and outdated electricity
infrastructure make them angry
and a mix of corruption mismanagement
and political crisis are making that to
us
we have four hours of blackouts followed
by two hours of service but when the
national electricity is on it's like
traffic lights it goes on and off all
the time
people here are suffering when these
cables are failing to deliver power to
their households but when they do they
become dangerous to human lives as their
left low hanging in residential areas
power Cuts has been a main instigator
for angry protests in Iraq in the past
few years under a 50 degrees Celsius
summer people had to live with blackouts
or pay for local generators
there's a gap between our demand and
Supply we need 35 000 megawatt of
electricity even if we secure 25 000 we
still need 10 000 megawatts we need more
stations in different cities also we
need new lines to all the provinces the
lack of budget is challenging our plans
that occupies gas and power from Iran to
cover a third of its needs but with
sanctions on Tehran payments have been
overdue Iran is struggling with
increased power demand and is cutting
power supplies that's putting more
pressure on Iraq's National electricity
Supply and for meeting megawatt Rafael
Iran is providing us with 1 200 megawatt
besides the gas we use in the plants
that produce 3300 megawatt of
electricity
there are also accusations electricity
is being used by Iran to maintain
influence and error to counter the
country's influence the U.S in college
Baghdad to sign a deal with the gulf
cooperation Council or GCC to get about
500 megawatts of energy for Iraq it's
very important to versify our relations
and to get Electric Supply from
different countries so that will not be
under pressure from any side when
or even with Jordan and Egypt since 2003
Iraq has spent more than 80 billion
dollars on upgrading its power grid
but many say they've yet to see the
benefits